[Music]  i don't think of you as an impressionist  but i i hear that you do a a spot on  shaquille o'neal impression when you're  trying to do an impression of shaquille  o'neal what's what's the key to it what  do you do you know you got to have a  lazy eye a little bit  i know y'all wanted to have my eyes like  this  but usually both of them is like this so  i know how to work the one  [Laughter]  but uh shaquille o'neal is a cool he's a  good friend of mine you know he got the  deep voice you know oh how about  i want to uh  i want to let you know somebody  you're a good friend of mine  i know  i mean the dude is big man some of his  some of this is the size of keys all  right  and when he went and when the boo-boo  come out he's like what's up little tony  robert good lord okay